[Music]
the supreme court has overturned roe v
wade the 1973 decision that established
a constitutional right to an abortion in
the u.s
[Applause]
now decisions on the legality of
abortion are left to the states this is
going to mean that access to abortion
will vary dramatically depending on
where you live
while 16 states and the district of
columbia have laws that protect the
right to an abortion 22 states have laws
that could ban all or most abortions now
that roe has been reversed according to
the guttmacher institute a policy group
that supports abortion rights and tracks
national abortion statistics
the organization details a patchwork of
laws among these states including
pre-road bans trigger laws and post-road
restrictions that will determine the
fate of abortion access in the u.s
[Applause]
nine states have bans on their books
that pre-date roe v wade which have been
unenforceable for the past five decades
some of them date back to the late 1800s
or early 1900s these could be laws that
could be enforced after this decision or
as a result of this decision
states like arkansas can now revive
their pre-road bans through official
enforcement or by filing court actions
however not all states with pre-road
bans are poised to enforce the laws
michigan governor gretchen whitmer and
abortion rights groups have filed
lawsuits to block the state's 1931 law
that makes providing an abortion at any
point during pregnancy a felony
a michigan judge through a preliminary
injunction said the state can't enforce
it whereas others in states like arizona
for example i know lawmakers there are
anticipating that they could enforce
their own pre-road ban on abortion
13 states have passed so-called trigger
laws on the condition they would go into
effect if the supreme court rescinded
the constitutional right to abortion
however each of these laws are quite
different from the other one and they
can take effect at different times in
kentucky louisiana and south dakota the
laws are enforceable immediately but in
texas idaho and tennessee there's a
30-day buffer period between roe's
reversal and when the laws go into
effect
in some states trigger laws can only be
implemented after state government
officials such as attorneys general or
governors certify the high court's
decision
some states including georgia and
alabama have sought to set stricter
limits on when abortions can be
performed during a pregnancy
georgia's ban on abortion around when
cardiac activity can be detected and
alabama's near total ban have previously
been blocked in court because they
conflicted with limits set by roe
now the elimination of these federal
protections for the procedure and the
reversal of the supreme court precedent
means that it's possible they can be
resurrected in some way
[Music]
some states don't have these specific
restrictions or protections for abortion
currently on the books and it remains to
be seen what actions they will take in
the future meanwhile abortion clinics in
more liberal states have been preparing
for an influx of patients they are
expanding their hours adding more staff
adding more days that they are available
to accommodate what they expect to be
even more patients coming in
abortion providers in more restrictive
states are also assessing how to support
patients who will need to travel outside
of the state for the procedure planning
and figuring out how they will navigate
this different and varying access to
abortion across this country will be
something that i'm sure will take some
time to really nail down and figure out